[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv
and recorded in london on thursday 6th
of may
i'm cindy yoo the spectator's broadcast
editor standing in for andrew neil
on the show today i'll be speaking to
neil ferguson not the imperial college
epidemiologist
but a historian who coined the term
chimerica he writes a spectator's cover
article this week
and we'll be discussing cold war ii and
more
we'll also be joined by jay bhattacharya
the stanford professor of medicine who
was one of the authors of the great
barrington declaration
about whether the indian government
should lock down before all that
we'll chat local elections and ask has
boris johnson
only just realized the cost of child
care in this country
all that to come in the next hour if you
enjoy the show and don't want to miss a
future episode
click the subscribe button on the bottom
right of your screen to follow our
youtube channel
for free first it's
super thursday a flurry of elections
across the uk are happening
from polls in scotland and wales to
local elections and mayoralties across
england there's even a by-election in
hartlepool
a red wall seat that doesn't look
certain to stay labour
so what should you be watching out for
as a result trickling over the next few
days
joining me now is the spectator's
political editor james forsyth and our
associate editor isabel hardman
james let's talk about super thursday in
just a moment but for now as we film
there are a couple of
royal navy boats in the english channel
patrolling against a french barricade
what's going on so there's been a
dispute about
how many licenses are being granted to
french
fishermen to fish off the coast of
jersey
the dispute massively escalated when the
french suggested
uh that jersey's electricity supply
which
largely comes from france might be cut
off uh if his situation wasn't sorted
out
then there was word of uh french fishing
vessels heading to kind of blockade
uh the port of saint helia and the
british government have responded by
sending
two uh royal navy vessels there
to kind of make a statement and and
prevent a blockade
and i think the danger i mean there is
clearly the
initial french threat was in century um
i i think boris johnson was talking in
his down street statement last night
about
the need to calm the situation down
while sending uh two royal navy vessels
which might be slightly contradictory
but but on a more serious
level there is a problem here which is
that these post-brexit disputes between
the uk and the eu
escalate very quickly uh and and this
isn't a healthy state for this
relationship
to be in i thought there was an irony
but last night
you had a long and detailed
g7 communique issued which was meant to
be part of the free world beginning to
push back on russia and china and then
the two largest military powers in
europe are are both sending vessels from
their own navy
uh to the channel in relation to a
fishing dispute
this is not sensible and i mean i mean
the two sides need to find a much better
way
of de-escalating these arguments but
before they reach this stage
and i think unless they can do that this
is going to set up a very
antagonistic choppy relationship from
now on
and it's really hard to imagine that
this won't at some point
bleed over into kind of uh
into foreign defense policy corporation
you know the uk and french navies are
meant to cooperate very closely they are
now you know facing off against each
other in the channel now
i don't think anyone is expecting this
situation to to result in
any kind of action of that sort but
it is still not healthy for the
uk eu relationship to get to kind of
battle stations
quite so quickly whenever a relatively
minor dispute and this is a very minor
dispute
occurs yes absolutely um but isabel
always are on the local elections across
the country today
as well as happening in wales and
scotland we've also got the mayoralties
and what are the places that we should
be watching out for
well we'll likely get the hartley pool
by-election result
first which as we've said on coffeehouse
shots podcasts
will probably set the narrative for the
next few days
as the other results come in the other
contests to really keep an eye on
are the west midlands mayoral contest
where
there's not just a row about who thinks
they're going to win you've got liam
byrne who's who's briefing very
stridently that
that he is going to win uh despite polls
suggesting
otherwise but you've also got
frustration within the labour party
towards
liam byrne for being quite so strident
ahead of the polls because it then makes
the west midlands
contest a bit like hartley pool in the
sense that if
labour loses that then it becomes a
problem for kirstalma as well
so there those around the labour leader
basically saying thanks liam for that
you know you could have you could have
just stayed a bit quiet or seemed
a little bit more humble uh in the
run-up to this result
we then have the results in scotland
which are going to be very interesting
to see how much of an
impact and asawa has made
in 10 weeks of being the new scottish
labour
leader and we've had if you look at the
visits that boris johnson and kirsten
made yesterday in the final hours of
campaigning
kierstarma was in pontefract he was in
the west midlands and he was also in the
west of england
on the mayoral campaign trail there as
well so those are clearly
areas that they're concerned about and
similarly boris johnson
was supporting andy street the tory
candidate to be re-elected as west
midlands mayor
james how are the tories feeling about
all of these elections and in particular
in hartlepool
i think the problem with the tories is
that that their expectations management
has gone rather arrived put it mildly
there is now
an assumption in westminster that the
tories will win
uh hartlepool the westminster and t
side now if the tories do win hardly
poor i think it it will
create problems for later it will
suggest that you know that kiyosama
hasn't managed to stop the bleeding in
the red wall
but i think that from where we are now
even if labor were to win hartlepool i'm
like a third recount by
10 votes you know i think i think
kirsten will be up there
first thing tomorrow morning proclaiming
a historic victory and saying the labor
fight back
starts here so i mean there is an
expectations management problem for the
tories
my expectation is that the incumbent
party in england scotland and wales so
in england that's the tories
in scotland that's the snp and in wales
it's the labour party
will all do fairly well because
uh they have answers to voters on what
have they done for you lately they'll
point to the furlough scheme and the
vaccine roll out
and i think we are still seeing that uh
this
in this crisis versus us pretending to
give
the government the incumbent whether
they'd be the westminster government or
would evolve governments in scotland and
wales
you know the benefit of a doubt and
israel obviously we're filming at a time
where the results are not
out yet but as you alluded to if kirsten
loses hartley pool he could have a
problem on his hands
how how big of a problem do you think
that would be because
clearly you know if kia someone loses a
red red bull seat
the narrative is no longer that jeremy
corbyn was the problem
yeah so i don't think you're going to
see a leadership challenge but what i
think you are going to
see or at least hear is a lot of
complaining
not just from the left of the labour
party who would obviously
seize on this as a sign that the starmah
project
to rescue the labour party from the
corbynites is not working but also
from those who have wanted kierstarma to
do well
and have seen him as a potential savior
of the party after its very torrid
past five or six years i think you'll
see
party grandes uh giving those sort of
coded interviews that you see
um after an embarrassing result for a
party where
they don't lay into the labour leader
but they start to say and i think you
know the great thing about keir is he
he really can turn up the volume or
something like that where they're
basically setting out what he needs to
do in their view
to improve matters and to stop the party
from from continuing to
to bleed red wall votes one thing i've
picked up that's really interesting
from those around the by-election
campaign and around starmar
is they've been quite keen to emphasize
that voters aren't as angry
this time around on the doorstep as they
have been in the past three elections
now that's an interesting argument and
it may well be true
anecdotally in something that has given
the activists who've campaigned in
hartlepool
uh at least some comfort that the voters
aren't shouting at them
anymore but if the voters were not angry
but still not voting for labour i'm not
really sure how that improves the
party's prospects because
you know people might feel sort of more
fondly towards labor
but if they just see it as being
something that they can discard to the
history books then that's
that's not really a measure of success
for kia stammer so you will see a lot of
pressure for him to
um to move on i think from what a lot of
his
uh anxious friends in the labour party
see as being a bit of bandwagon jumping
but also a caution around certain things
there's
a mix of frustration that he can be
knocked around by um rouse on twitter
and
shadow cabinet members who come to him
saying people are getting very cross
about this thing on twitter
therefore we have to take a position i'm
thinking particularly
of the measures on protests that the
government is currently legislating for
that
kirstama has now decided to oppose the
entire bill
uh containing that which has got you
know tougher sentences
for for criminals uh committing a range
of offenses and there's a lot of people
on labour's front bench who are saying
well
how on earth did we end up in this
position where we're appearing to
to not want to be tough on crime um but
also i think you'll also
see um you also see people saying well
but he's also at the same time he's
jumping on bandwagons he's incredibly
cautious and he doesn't make the big
calls when he needs to he waits until
it's inevitable that something's going
to be announced almost to the point that
actually journalists have
have had the the operational note saying
it's going to happen and then he calls
for it saying the government really
needs to go for this
knowing full well that the government is
going to go for it and they want him to
be a little bit more fleet of foot
now one place that labour may do quite
well in is wales with mark drakeford
but james that's looking pretty tight
isn't it
yeah the tories did very well in wales
in the 2019 general election
uh but i mean the polls at the moment
seem to suggest that labour will remain
as the largest party in wales
even if uh short of a majority and i
think i mean you see
that you know that again i think labor
in wales are
benefiting from the vaccination roll out
i think wales is further ahead on the
vaccination program than any other part
of the uk
but um but i think this is i think there
is
the challenge for labor is going to be
what is going to be working out you know
i think is actually not overreacting to
these results
i i think the danger is that the left of
the lady party
who feel and they have a point on this
that kierstarma
um kind of campaigned for labour leader
or almost offering a kind of carbonite
policy prospectus but just without
jeremy corbyn and his own
personal baggage uh i i think it is fair
to say that as leader that has not been
the approach that he has taken so i
think you will see
a lot of noises off from the labor left
if if labor have a bad set of results
tonight and at the same time as isabel
said it's hard to
say what labour is for um i think you
know labour's attacks on sleeves
have almost be they they have almost
gone so hard on sleeves because they
haven't got
anything else to say and at the moment
it's quite hard to sum up what labour's
offer to the electorate is
and as well when it comes to labor north
of the border they might be doing better
than they were
before you interviewed the scottish
labour leader anna sawa for the magazine
this week can you tell us
what he was like yeah he's uh he's the
one with the who's had the momentum
in this hollywood election campaign he's
the one who as he says in
my interview has enjoyed this campaign
nicholas sturgeon
obviously uh started this election
campaign in a very uncomfortable
position given
uh the uh the row over her uh
her destroyed relationship with alex
salmond and her
former mentor's decision to set up a new
political party
that he claims will help the cause of
independence but is obviously part of
his sort of revenge project against
nicola sturgeon then you've got the
scottish conservatives who are still so
obviously desperately missing ruth
davidson to the extent that
she often appears far more prominently
on their campaign leaflets
and in their media opportunities than
the actual leader
douglas ross who's had a quite a wooden
performance
in these elections so anasawa is the one
who has got a bit more freedom to enjoy
himself
and his pitch is not to talk about the
constitution but to say that it's
important to
to focus on a national plan for recovery
and to talk about this being a pandemic
election rather than just to go on and
on
about independence if you look at
scottish conservative leaflets in
particular
they are basically saying stop a
referendum vote conservative to stop a
referendum whereas
his strategy for labour is to talk to
people who
may have voted yes in 2014 uh who
who might still be minded to support
independence in future
but he wants to try and bring them on
side so that scottish labour can
can go back to being the official
opposition in the scottish parliament
yeah he certainly looks like he's having
fun actually that was that video that
went viral recently of him dancing
to uptown funk which we can watch a bit
of now
and as well you mentioned that douglas
ross was a bit wooden and actually i did
cringe a little bit when i saw
his response to um to popular culture
references his here's douglas ross
talk us through your dance routine if it
comes to our dance off for second place
well i've made it very clear you know i
am a big fan of atomic kitten whole
again not only can i
sing the lyrics without the computer
screen and i don't need the words to it
you know i've made up my own
actions too and it just makes the whole
performance so you know you know
if you see me walking down the street
staring at the sky dragging my two feet
you just pass me by it still makes me
cry but colin you can meet me all again
well let me also bring in stephen
daisley who is a spectator contributor
and a columnist for the scottish daily
mail
stephen having seen those two videos
side by side you know who would you
who would you say as a more charismatic
leader who would you vote for
well i i don't think that there's um
there's much in it
um as in so far as i think you know
as isabel has just said you know anna
sarwar has had
a sort of a campaign that he's clearly
enjoyed in fact it reminds me of
the campaign that ruth davidson had in
2015 for the general election
where her her way of thinking was that
you know there's no way that the
scottish conservatives was going to do
well in the 2015 general election so
i'll spend this election
you know going out having fun drumming
up um media
interest and i can then build on that
for future elections which
she then did to to quite some success uh
and anna sarwar seems to be doing
something
um very similar you know uh douglas ross
it's
um oh you know i almost feel sorry for
him hard-hearted cynic though i
am um and that you know douglas schwartz
has actually
you know put out a manifesto um and that
is you know to some extent
actually quite well costed and lots of
interesting policies in there
and sort of things like funding for
mental health and you know how do we
address care social care after the
pandemic and all these things
the problem is that his messaging has
been largely about independence and him
sort of standing you know almost kind of
angrily pointing and saying
independence is a terrible thing and
vote for us if you don't want it
uh and you know the the more he kind of
tells how terrible independence is
voters seem to think actually maybe it's
not independence that's terrible douglas
i mean stephen on ana sawas campaign i
found a blog that you wrote for
coffeehouse recently very interesting
talking about you know this is not a
constitutional
election way of talking about things but
you were saying that he's actually
playing that card
a bit too soon that he should be waiting
a few more years before he says
guys let's not talk about the referendum
now yeah i wonder about you know i think
that
you know on the face of it dana sarwar
has
has sort of won the battle of the
campaigns if that's if there's
really such a thing as that outside of
the political bubble
and i do wonder though if there was an
opportunity this election for nsr were
actually to have targeted
um sort of more traditionally pro-union
voters
um with a sort of a solid message on the
union which
you know scottish labour has gone all
over the place on the union in the past
few years
and you know and i do wonder if perhaps
he could have gone a bit
you know it could have solidified the
message on the union you'll
apply you know what peeled away some of
uh the more sort of soft tory voters
um and then you know had uh potentially
had a chance
at uh going into second place he might
still do that but i think that it's
you know as things stand right now i
think it's probably more likely that the
tories will hold on to second
place um and if he'd done that this time
you know then
you know five years from now he could
have gone for the uptown funk
upbeat positive uh campaign um
uh but you know who knows we will we
will find out
in the next 40 hours or so and who was
right and who was wrong
yes james what would you reckon could
anasawa have a realistic chance at
second place
in this race as steven says most of the
polls indicate that scottish stories
will hang on to this
uh and it seems that kind of unionist
tactical voting is most likely to to
benefit
them rather than scottish labour i think
that anastasia's emergence in this
campaign
is an important moment in terms of
thinking about scholars politics in the
in the long term because
i think alasa has a kind of credibility
as first
minister that we haven't as a potential
first minister that we haven't seen from
a scottish labour leader
or really the last two scottish tory
leaders uh
and i think that that will make a
difference uh i also think that in terms
of any future campaign
you know he he his ratings are are
positive
uh the more people have seen of him the
more they've lied to him and that could
be very important in terms of indirect
too because
they're gonna they're gaping gap in any
kind of unionist
campaign was someone who could appeal to
uh social democratic voters who may be
leaning towards independence
uh but because they don't like the idea
of kind of tory governments at
westminster
but but they but but aren't kind of full
on uh on
nationalists and i think he is quite up
is quite well suited to appealing to
that kind of vote to come any second
independence referendum
well stephen let's talk about nicolas
sturgeon for a little bit i mean
we've we've seen the psycho drama that's
happened in scotland over the last
uh year or so but despite alex salmon's
best efforts nicholas sturgeon is still
in place and she still looks set to be
first minister
so has all of this just shown how teflon
she is
i think yes it has shown how teflon
nickel surgeon is but also has shown
that you know the the snp has this
built-in baked in volt
that is of roughly 40 to 45 percent
of the electorate that 45 number will
sound familiar because of course that's
the percentage of scots who voted for
independence in 2014
and the snp's message is essentially you
know
stick with us and you know that will
be the surest way to get independence as
sort of reminiscent of the old liberal
slogan in the 70s you know one
one last heave and nicola sturgeon soft
gradualist approach echoes that in some
ways
um it's true that you know alex salmond
has
um certainly not made much of an impact
or not much of a positive impact
on this campaign i think they uh most
commented about of
of the alaba party has been its of
technical snafus its various launches
and
uh also that really very weird video
that it did where
uh appeared to have summoned up the
spirit of robert the bruce um
from 700 years ago to uh to a sort of
brand about um
breaking the spine of english
superiority uh banibar was very strange
but you know that appeals to the kind of
sort of
you know hardcore nationalist voter that
alex hammond is
is pitching to you know his messages
give aliba give me your
your second vote your list vote and you
know we will sort of if you like
strengthen the snp
spine um but you know i would say
nicolas sergeant has um
you know she is going to be the first
minister you know after this election
there's no doubt about that
and i would say we're talking earlier
about who enjoyed the campaigns nicholas
sergeant has not looked like she has
enjoyed this campaign
you know she has looked like this was a
grinning beric campaign
and you know in some ways suppose you
can't blame her she's coming off the
back of
you know these very punishing hollywood
inquiries and and the fact that at the
center of it was
something you know deeply personal for
her the
breakup of this you know becky's long
political relationship with alex salmond
um i i think as well there's maybe a bit
of a frustration there
um that you know as we've seen that
although the polls are good for the smb
right now they're not necessarily good
for independence and in some
some polls are actually going in the
other direction um and you're seeing
support for independence drop
uh so nicolas surgeon you know could be
in the the position where she wins this
election even wins an outright majority
at holyrood um but at the same time the
polls turn against
uh scottish independence which is
you know sod's law writ large
stephen looking ahead has nicola
sturgeon box herself in a little bit
when it comes to a second referendum
because
she's ruled out um a wildcat referendum
an illegal one that westminster
does not sanction but at the same time
she's pledged to get a referendum within
two and a half years
of her being re-elected i mean nicholas
sturgeon has
uh set herself a very very difficult
task and now nicholas sergeant has
uh has you know uh completed many many
difficult tasks remember this is the
the woman who uh you know was
responsible for that famous
2015 smb landslide that wiped out
um the uh the um all that wiped out the
scottish labour party
you know she you know had a set back in
2017 and then roared right back
in 2019 um so she's you know incredibly
capable politician
um but the the sort of high bar she has
to reach now when on a second referendum
is
possibly too high even for her you know
she has
she has an activist base and also
backbenchers who are really impatient
for a second referendum
um her argument in this campaign is that
you you know westminster can't silence
scotland's voice
okay that's fair enough but if you then
do get this majority which
um nicholas sergeant claims is a mandate
for a second referendum
and eventually you're going to have to
demand that referendum and at some point
ideally deliver that referendum
and the problem is if westminster says
no one that seems to be what boris
johnson has minded to do just now
uh is one of those you know you and
whose army
sort of questions um potentially the
uh you know that has been hinted that
the scottish government
could you know um some go ahead with a
referendum
allow this to be tested in the courts
and the problem with that is first of
all
it looks a bit ambulance chasing that
you're suing your way
or you're or you're sort of being sued
out of of of going for independence also
you know what happens if the court said
no this uh the constitution was reserved
to westminster
and then nicolas sergeant is left with a
majority of hollywood
a very unhappy uh base and
potentially parliamentary party and no
feasible way of achieving
a referendum that she that she really
has to achieve
to keep her coalition together james
forsythe isabel hardman and stephen
daisley thank you for joining spectator
tv
now the prime minister has been dogged
by stories surrounding his flat
renovations
in the run-up to these elections but it
might not be the only thing that boris
johnson has tried to get tory donors to
pay for
number 10 is refusing to deny reports
that the prime minister approached a
donor to pay for baby wilfred's child
care
in this week's magazine journalist
isabel oakshot lays out the costs of
child care in the uk these days
and asks has the prime minister only
just realized how expensive it is
she joins the program now israel oak
shot welcome to spectator tv
now you've been doing some back of the
envelope calculations tell us about
those
well this is an exercise i'd completely
avoided doing for all these years mainly
because i just didn't really want to
know what the total amount that i had
spent on child care has been
um my oldest child is now nearly 14
my youngest is eight and so obviously
i've had a very long period of paying
for child care full-time i've worked all
the way through
um and when i read that boris
apparently has been struggling a little
bit with the
extra cost of finding child care for his
baby
wilfred i i kind of thought actually
you know what it really is i have some
sympathy here it really is
a big hit although boris being the
father of
six children that we know of you would
have thought by now this wouldn't have
come as a surprise to him
so i thought look this is time to face
facts let's have a look at how much i've
spent over the years
and it was very much back of the
envelope because like any parent
a full-time working parent my child care
arrangements are complicated
um i don't just have a full-time nanny i
also
until brexit destroyed the au pair
market i also had an au pair because i
need
overnight help sometimes and you know
often there's extra help at
odd times of day and night and weekends
so i really just took a kind of
a general figure of how much it cost to
have had a nanny for all these years
and the figure i came out with was i'm
afraid well over half a million pounds
um
honestly i i am actually still slightly
in shock even though i knew
that it was going to be a big figure i
mean that is one
hell of a sum um and you know to some
extent it's prompted a bit of
soul-searching you know how how could i
have spent that amount
on child care i mean have i been
unbelievably stupid was there a better
way of doing things
um and you know many people hearing that
figure will think
my goodness she must have had no time at
all with her children
and actually ironically that isn't true
i'm lucky enough
um for the last few years certainly to
have had an enormous amount of
flexibility
over the way i work and actually i do
the school run
most days one of the school runs because
there are multiple school runs to do
you know and i am lucky enough to spend
probably considerably more time with the
children than most working parents
the reality is that half a million
pounds is probably
not that unusual for professional
parents either single parents like me
or whether are two working parents in
the household and they need full-time
care
over a very long period so you know
i'm sort of slowly recovering from the
shock
i also did some quick back of the
envelope calculations and worked out the
annual cost of that around 36 000 pounds
and that's
after tax so you know you'd have to
you'd have to have a partner or be
earning quite a lot before tax
in order to afford that and it's about
why is it so expensive as you say you've
not been
stupid about it so where does the cost
come from
so essentially with a full-time nanny
you are paying for a professional
and you're paying a decent salary for
somebody of the caliber that you will be
as a mother or father happy to leave
your children with
and rightly they have to be paid
properly through the all the normal
channels you've got to pay national
insurance contributions you are
effectively
an employer running a mini business as
it were
um and good nannies are hard to find and
they rightly command decent salaries
and in terms of trying to to get
something
cheaper um perhaps the sort of the most
flexible model there is with
if you're trying to avoid going down the
very expense of nanny route
is a child minder and these are people
that tend to
look after a small group of children in
their own homes they're allowed to look
after
up to eight of different age groups and
they are actually a
relatively affordable solution for
parents that don't want to put their
little ones in nursery for whatever
reason or nurseries don't offer the
flexibility
the difficulty with child minders is
that a they can be quite hard to find
they're in hot demand
and b they often they don't have quite
the setup that you as a parent want you
know perhaps a house isn't big enough
they don't have quite a big enough
garden you know you may as a mother not
particularly want your child to be with
the mix that that child minder
has at that time so i think for a lot of
professionals and nanny is the only
answer
and you know in fairness when i think
about my
half a million pounds i've had a lot for
my money
you know my fabulous nanny i'm lucky
enough to have had the same
lady for the last seven years which has
just been a godsend and she does
an awful lot more than look after the
children and i think
as children get older a lot of
professional families
uh they keep their nannies on to do so
many other things other than
uh the the sort of traditional uh
child's care role
uh but it this isn't something that
comes cheap and you know for me it is
effectively
a cost of doing business of running uh
the household and doing what i do
and in all these years i know that my
children have had
you know the highest quality child care
that i could afford
but that doesn't still take away from me
kind of thinking what else could i have
spent that money on
yes and it makes a lot of sense when you
think that you know for example the acd
says that child care costs
take up to average woman's half of their
salary so i mean that's that's a
hefty cost as you've talked about you
mentioned au pairs and how brexit has
impacted that presumably that's because
the stop to
freedom of movement and there's not a
specific au pair visa
for these young european women who come
here to learn a bit of culture and in
exchange for their child care services
you were a vocal supporter of brexit i
know i know where this is going but do
you
did you overlook it maybe if i'd known
it was going to destroy the au pair
market i might have thought differently
um what i would have thought i didn't
know by the way that there was going to
be
a total disaster with the open market
when i supported brexit but of course it
wouldn't have made me feel any different
about brexit because i would have
assumed
that this really wouldn't have been a
difficult thing to sort out
you know the government now is saying uh
you should employ british people to do
this well this is
insane i mean how many british people do
you know who are
prepared to work for 90 pounds a week
for 25 hours child care living in
someone else's house
just doesn't stack up for most people
there may be some
students that find that there is a way
of fitting that round and it's actually
quite
um economic for them to do that because
they've got free board and lodging and
they're doing a bit of child care around
there
around their courses but the whole point
of the au pair
exchange program was that these young
women and many of them that you know
they are very young they come over at
1920
uh are learning the language that's the
the origins
of the au pair cultural program uh and
so
there is something in it for them beyond
just having the
free roof over their head and a bit of
an adventure and that has just
completely gone you know you go on the
au pair world website
and you will see that there are dozens
and dozens of
parents chasing every single au pair
that says they've got pre-settled status
and so they are free to work in the uk
and you know talking informally to other
parents
this has really hit family's heart
and finally let's talk a little bit
about boris which is why we're talking
about the story at all because whilst a
lot of parents have been dealing with
this
has not really been in the news because
i guess a lot of parents just think this
is the way things are done
not the prime minister apparently
because he's reportedly been trying to
get tory donors
to try to pay for his uh for wilfred's
uh child care costs
what do you make of that and do you
think that's the sort of stuff that's
actually
going to be more important than the flat
renovation story
well it agitated me but
in a sort of conflicted way as i say
because i have some sympathy for him
in in the cost of it look i think that
what people think
is they they feel that something is
wrong here they feel that uh
it's extraordinary that someone of the
prime minister's stature
and independent means because make no
mistake boris johnson is a
very wealthy and successful individual
he was before he became prime minister
he commands
huge fees for his writing and his books
how can he be scratching around
and finding himself beholden to people
asking them
to pay for his partner's gold wallpaper
choices
people are i think they're just a little
incredulous
about it is it cutting through i think a
bit
i think it was a slow burn this story
it's been rumbling along for a long time
and only now i think allegation after
allegation
it is beginning to cut through a bit but
the reality is
of course people are dealing with far
bigger issues
they still think boris johnson is a good
prime minister that's what the polls
suggest they certainly think
he's better than anyone else who's
putting their name forward for the job
right now
and so i think he'll weather this uh
pretty well
that said there's clearly one or two
things that he doesn't want to tell us
about this sorry saga and you know when
politicians keep avoiding the question
there's a reason for that
something more is yet to come out would
it bring him down i'd be
very very surprised indeed but it's it's
uncomfortable you've got to feel
for the couple themselves you know
looking around at their gold wallpaper
must have seriously taken the tinge off
it you know really
are they enjoying their fancy lamp
shades i can't imagine they really are
it's about eggshell thanks very much you
can read isabel's article and more of
our print and online offerings with a
spectator subscription
as a thank you for watching the show
we'll even give you 12 weeks for just 12
pounds
and a 20 pound amazon gift card go to
spectator dot co dot uk forward slash tv
offer
and sign up today next the g7r meeting
in london this week but the indian
delegation has had to self-isolate
because of two cases
of confirmed covert in limits really
bringing home the sheer scale of the
infections in india at the moment
there are more than 350 000 new
infections each day
the opposition in the country is calling
for another national lockdown
but so far the government is resisting
in this week's issue of the spectator
stanford professor jay batacharya you
might remember having heard his name
from the great barrington declaration
explains just why the government is so
reluctant to put the country
into another lockdown jay welcome to
spectator tv
so tell us why is the modi government so
reluctant to impose another national
lockdown
the lockdown uh was tried in india the
the
draconian sharp lockdown imposed you
sort of with almost no notice
in the early days of the epidemic last
year and it had absolutely devastating
consequences
migrant workers for instance who work in
cities uh were forced to walk
some in some cases hundreds thousands of
thousand miles
uh to go home almost 900 died
uh on route uh some people have called
it like the
india's trail of tears it in some ways
it's the biggest forced migration within
india since the 1947 partition
um and it was absolutely devastating and
uh there's a lot and
if you have to ask also in addition all
these harms uh
from the the immediate impositional
lockdown they're also longer term
harms uh many many programs that are
vital to the health of indians
and actually the people around the world
for programs like uh
treating tuberculosis patients you know
that takes
a year of of constant application of
antibiotics
um vaccination programs basic
vaccination programs for childhood
diseases
a whole host of other health uh
priorities were basically thrown out the
window for the indian lockdown
and with great harm to the health of the
indian population
enormous death uh one u.n report
estimated that last year in india
and south asia at large more than 200
000 children had died as a consequence
of the nutritional deprivation
and medical deprivations of lockdown the
lockdown means something very different
in the west than it does in the united
states
than it does in india and um i think uh
if you look at what happened with the
first lockdown i
i think that it's just an unimaginable
thing to do to have a sharp
national lockdown in india again and
you know i think when it comes to the
different health questions like
tuberculosis vaccines you know that's
something that we have heard about
here in the west but what we haven't
heard about much is these migrant
workers
um you know can you talk a little bit
about the structure of the indian
economy and what these migrant workers
are doing
and why did they have to return to their
villages on foot why was that a
situation at all
i mean it wasn't the lockdown was was
ordered with very very short notice
and the indian economy that it is
actually
in some ways it is has has grown much
more uh
uh sort of national in scope they're
people who work
outside of their villages they find work
in cities they sell
you know just for example maybe they're
you you sell coconut water for a living
right you buy coconut water
in the morning uh you you sell it you
with the money you get you buy your food
for the day
and then you buy more coconut water that
night that you sell the next morning
right it's it's a it's a cycle that
you're just repeating if
it's broken you go hungry that day um
it's uh and the
the workers come there from the from
their villages because
that's where the opportunities are into
the cities so when the lockdown was
instituted
the the government essentially said go
back to your home villages quarantine
your home villages
and that's why uh people were
essentially had to go there very far
with almost no provisions for many many
people
for the poorest no provision of
transportation um
with you know i guess with predictable
devastating effects um
just heartbreaking how much of it is the
problem with how the government
conducted lockdown i mean
an oxford university study found that
india's lockdown last year was actually
among the strictest
in the world could there have been some
kind of halfway house where
they allowed the trains to still run
they had some health services
going on in the same way that the uk
second lockdown for example
cancer services were not as pushed back
as they were in the first lockdown is it
so is it a problem of
how it was implemented rather than
having a lockdown
at all i mean i think the problem is
that lockdown
um i mean i i get sort of well known for
not thinking that they work very well in
the west
um but i i think in india it really was
hopeless
to actually imp ins so what is a
lockdown a lockdown is an attempt
to end human interaction or to pause
human interaction
to make sure that people are apart from
one another for an extended period of
time
so that they don't have spread covert
disease to one another
um the problem with that is that in a
nation like india that is that is going
to automatically
have devastating consequences and
actually the other side of it is
given the living arrangements of many
many many many poor indians
it was it was destined to fail to stop
the spread of covet in the first
wave of covid um there have been a whole
sequence of
zero prevalence studies the super
problem study is a measure of as a study
that checks
the presence of antibodies in the
population at large antibodies suggest
that someone has already been infected
with covert
uh there was a study done last i think
july in mumbai
that found in the harvey slums that
almost
60 percent 57 of the of the residents
in july of last year had already been
infected
whereas at mumbai at large you know the
cosmopolitan city was
with you know many many uh affluent
people the sierra problem was only
i think 16 there was an enormous gap
between the rich and the poor
in who was exposed in the first wave in
india
um that lockdown if anything protected
the
affluent class the the class of people
who could work from home and work from
work through zoom it did absolutely
nothing to protect the poor
from the disease so at our current
juncture then
if not locked down what do you think the
indian government should do
i mean i think the union government
actually one of the great things it's
done is it secured vaccines
at a rate a level that many many other
countries haven't had i mean the us and
uk of course were spoiled because we
have had
access to the vaccines almost for you
know many months
um and uh in the since january the
indian government is vaccinating
somewhere on the order of
uh 10 of its population which is an
amazing achievement actually for
a country of that size and that income
level
uh india is is the engine of vaccination
vaccine
production for cope and many of the
vaccines that the west uses
are actually made in india um and uh so
it it's it's in i think using the
vaccine
it cleverly is the way out for india for
this
who's the who's really vulnerable this
disease this disease if you're over the
age of
of say 70 the the death rate's very very
high except you know 90
uh the the survival rate is something
like 95 percent not
five percent mortality rate or higher is
very very high infection fatality rate
if you're over 70. if you're under 70
it's much lower something like
0.05 percent 99.95 survival according
according to a whole sequence of studies
um and so you have this thousand-fold
difference between the risk of
death from people that are younger
versus people that are older
the critical priority in india and
frankly even in the west
is to protect the older population and
in the uk and the us we've done that
we've prioritized the old for
vaccination
and in in in a way we defang the disease
it no longer is the case that you will
have
cases automatically leading to deaths in
the us and the uk because
the the set of people who are most at
risk from death from the disease have
been have been vaccinated
india should do the same thing
unfortunately in january when they had
this opportunity
they vaccinated 10 of the population but
they did a couple of things wrong
one is they didn't vaccinate the old
preferentially only i think 40 percent
of the doses
have gone to people uh that are that 40
42
of the doses have gone to people that
are 60 and older uh
and uh i mean i think that was a mistake
i think that the the uh if those doses
had been concentrated on the old
we might have seen the cases spread in
india but we would not be seeing the
deaths we
were seeing um the second and you know
we don't see you wouldn't also see the
hospitalizations there'd be much less
pressure on the indian health care
system as well
the other uh the other thing i think
that they made a mistake on this you
know there are
a large fraction of the population in
india already been exposed based on
these earlier serial problem studies
they should have used that information
to prioritize who gets the vaccine
if you are already been infected you are
very likely protected against
reinfection
most likely even immune the immunity
that you get from natural infection
is at least as good as the vaccine
of course it's worse you had to go
through kobe to get it but it's you know
it's it's still
at least that that's that one one good
good outcome well given that's the case
the vaccine should be used on people who
were not
previously infected you could save a lot
of doses prioritize the people will not
be disinfected completely unprotected
rather than giving the vaccine doses
early on to people who were already
protected from previous infection well
that all makes a lot of sense but what
about
now i mean you mentioned in january they
should have done this given that india
is in the
in the grasps of this infection wave now
shouldn't the government lock down for
you know two weeks or so
just to get ahead of things well i mean
i think i know i think
it's possible that it's peaked already
again i don't think the lockdown will
help
stop the spread of disease didn't look
didn't work last time it very likely
won't
work this time and it uh as we as we
talked about beginning it had a huge
amount of
collateral damage i think the right
thing to do
is for the uh is actually accelerate the
vaccination campaign
the west should be helping i mean
there's no reason for in the west for us
to prioritize vaccinations for
20 year olds who are very very low risk
of severe outcomes from the disease
when there are elderly people not just
in india but around the world
that are entirely unprotected um we
should be
sending our doses to places that have
vulnerable elements there's no ethical
reason why
uh someone living in bolivia as is 80
year old
is less a lower priority for a vaccine
than a 20 year old american
um it doesn't make sense so go ahead
yeah can i say so there are as far as
the immediate need there are immediate
needs uh
pulse oximeters would help triage
patients so since that west can
help by sending medical i think the
united states is sending some medical
equipment but not at scale
that would be necessary um oxygen is in
very very short supply there's there's
you know black markets in oxygen now
with the price of oxygen 10 times
um i think there's some basic things
like that would go a long way
we also have like monoclonal antibody
treatments that might help uh that we
can send i think we could we there's
uh now that we that uh the the focus of
the disease moved to india
let's use the resources that we have i
mean what
you're asking you okay good friends with
india that's what good friends are for
it
is to help in time of need i think this
is this is that time no
absolutely but the problem is that you
paint this decision between
an 80 year old indian and a 20 year old
brit for example but if the vaccine
rollout has not been age prioritized in
the way that you describe
if britain gives india its vaccines how
do we know that it will be actually
used for the most vulnerable i mean i
think you you know i'm no expert in
diplomacy i'm just a simple professor
but um
i i think uh i think you could you could
say look uh we'll send you this if you
if you change your prioritization system
i mean i think that you could you could
condition it and i don't think that the
indian government would blink at that
jay bhattacharya thank you for joining
spectator tv
and remember that you can get full
access to the spectators online and
print articles with a subscription just
go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer and we'll even
throw in a 20 pound amazon voucher when
you subscribe for just one pound a week
finally has the pandemic revealed the
true nature of the west relationship
with china
the historian neil ferguson argues in
this week's cover article that
while the perception of china is worse
than it has been in many recent decades
the west also seems to be taking from
the beijing playbook
it's one of the ideas that he explores
in his new book doom the politics of
catastrophe
neil ferguson joins me now from
stanford's university's hoover
institution
neil welcome to spectator tv let's start
by talking about this concept you
mentioned of osmosis in war
what does that mean well this is an idea
that
i i came across when i was reading
norman mailers
the naked and the dead researching a
book about world war
ii years ago now the book was the war of
the world
and the idea is that you kind of become
like your
enemy uh even if you win that that's the
notion
and it was an idea that came up in world
war ii of course because
the democracies had to create enormous
systems of planning and control
to win world war ii uh and then in the
cold war
uh a recurrent theme of of commentary
from conservatives and
from the left as well think of george
orwell
was that there was a kind of convergence
happening and the united states and its
allies were
becoming more and more like the soviet
union
and its allies this was an idea john
kenneth galbraith
uh wrote up in the 1960s so
this idea of the osmosis of war that you
become like your enemy i think is
relevant today
because there's a danger that we could
become
uh are becoming uh more and more like
our principal strategic rival the
people's republic of china
and what are the ways do you think that
this is manifesting in
well there are a bunch for example joe
biden on the phone to boris johnson
saying
hey we need to have our own one belt one
road
uh initiative uh there's the way that
last year when it was clear that covert
19 was spreading
uh more or less uncontrolled through the
uk and the us we
we copied much that the chinese did the
idea of
of lockdowns was in many ways based on
what china did after
around january the 23rd last year when
they basically
froze uh the the chinese
economy and and chinese society
i i saw an interview the other day uh
with the other neil ferguson i'm not
him the guy at imperial college who
spells his name a bit differently
in which he said well we we didn't know
if we could do lockdowns
and then the chinese showed us as that
it could happen and then we
we discovered we could do it even though
we're not a communist state
so that's another example and i i could
go on i think central bank digital
currency is a good example
the chinese have pioneered this idea and
suddenly everybody's saying
where's the fed's central bank digital
currency where's the bank of england the
bank of england has set up a task force
to explore
this idea so across the board i think
we're seeing the osmosis of of cold war
in
in cold war too and what's particularly
fascinating about that neil ferguson's
interviews he said
we then we realized we could get away
with it and i remember writing a piece
in february last year about china's
we're hand locked down thinking this
could never happen
in the uk but then of course it happened
all across the west
when it comes to the security versus
liberty
tension do you think that a lot of the
west's are leaning towards security in
the last year especially on covet
it's because of this sort of state of
emergency that we've been in this global
pandemic scaring people into this
and so after the threat is over maybe
we'll be less like china in that way
well in do i try to argue that it wasn't
a straightforward choice between
letting the virus rip and getting to
herd immunity
as it were naturally and locking
everything down
that was the wrong choice uh to think
about that there was a choice
it existed in in january which was to do
what the taiwanese did and the south
koreans did
uh they didn't lock down in fact taiwan
has never had
a lockdown what they did was to ramp up
testing because it was possible to
test for the new virus very early on
once it had been
uh genetically sequenced uh at the same
time
to create a system of contact tracing uh
and then to
make be able to isolate or quarantine
people who are suspected of being ill
they they did that
very quickly uh and as a result hardly
anybody in taiwan has died of
of covert 19 i think the grand total is
11
to date despite the fact that they're
right next door
to the people's republic so i think one
obvious question for public health
officials in the west is
why didn't you do that why did you sit
around
january february and into mid-march
really not doing very much at all
and then in mid-march you read neil
ferguson's report panicked at the
thought that there were going to be
2.2 million deaths in the u.s half a
million in the uk
and and then you shut everything down in
this very indiscriminate way
that had lots of unintended consequences
the full scale of which i don't think we
we understand even even today so i i
think one has to realize that there were
other options
but we decided and i think it was a
wrong decision to copy
the people's republic of china rather
than to copy the republic of china
taiwan if we'd copied the taiwanese
playbook
we would have had i'm absolutely sure
significantly less
excess mortality and much much less
economic disruption
now you could say uh contact tracing
apps on our phones that sounds like
that sounds like a terrible threat to
civil liberties but i can assure you
it's a
it's a smaller threat than being under
house arrest as a great many of us were
for a large part of
of last year i mean if if if it's civil
liberty to be
to be shut in your own home under a
shelter-in-place order
then uh as ian hislock once said i'm a
banana
although taiwan does shut down its
borders pretty early on because it was
suspicious of the people's republic of
china i mean do you think that's
an acceptable trade-off to make
throughout history and
times of plague there have been
restrictions on travel
and one of the strangest things about
2020 was
how slow the us and the uk were
to realize that uh it was clearly
not wrong for donald trump to argue back
in january that there should be a travel
ban that there should be limits
on passengers coming into the us from
china but
uh he came up with the idea a couple of
weeks too late for really to make much
impact and of course there were
exceptions so u.s citizens and green
card holders were exempt the same is
true by the way
today indians can't travel
freely to the united states but indians
with green cards can
and u.s citizens who've been in india
can and that isn't going to stop the
indian variant from
arriving in the united states so yeah i
mean the taiwanese response which of
course at its counterparts in australia
and new zealand and other countries
was the right one when there's a new
pathogen running a mark in a country
stop people coming from that country
regardless of what passport or visa they
have
that's that's the kind of knowledge that
they already had about plagues back in
the middle ages
and let's talk about the cold war um you
you mentioned your book that cold war ii
has
already started and and you argue that
china
is the aggressor to this from from what
i what i've been talking to people with
in china and
whether it's academics or people they
actually think that is the west
who are itching to start a cold war too
what do you say to those people
well as a visiting professor at xinhua i
have quite a few
chinese academic friends and and friends
in
the world of chinese policy i've been
struck by how readily
they've accepted the cold war ii analogy
uh there's not a lot of pushback when
you when you make
this kind of argument uh of course as in
the first cold war
uh the communist side always argues that
it was the west that started it uh but
but this is a pretty unconvincing
argument i think when you look back on
xi jinping's track record since he
he came to power in china because really
from that moment on china's been far
more
explicit in its geopolitical and
technological
ambitions uh and as i try and show in
the book
discussions within uh the chinese
intelligentsia
uh are really quite explicit about the
objective of displacing
the united states as the dominant world
empire
uh with the people's republic of china
uh when you think about the way in which
china has increased its uh national
security expenditures its capabilities
uh its militarization of the south china
sea it's increasing assertiveness
towards
uh other asian countries think of the
way it's been beaten
it's been beating up on australia
recently it's kind of hard to claim that
that cold war ii started uh in
washington as opposed to
to beijing and i think we're rather in
the us in the same situation that we
were in at the beginning of
of cold war one in in the 1940s when
george orwell and winston churchill said
we're in a cold war most americans were
very slow to
accept that there was a sort of denial
that that persisted
almost until the outbreak of the korean
war in 1950
and i think we're still at that stage
now in cold war too a lot of
intellectuals
at stanford or harvard would say no no
this isn't cold war
ii that's the wrong analogy we should be
striving for co-opetition
with china which is a hideous word i
think this is the stage of denial that
you typically find in the west at the
beginning of a cold war well i guess
part of their worries is probably that
you know in a cold war as we saw in in
the 60s
you know we had people on both sides
kind of characterizing
each other as these uh one-sided
one-dimensional
players and actors and in many ways
china is not quite like the ussr it's
not ideologically driven in the same way
that the ussr was it seems much more
keen on lining its pockets
uh wherever possible um so do you think
that
the cold war mentality you know sorry
the cold war parallel
has limitations in how to understand
china as the new
strategic threat well i think it's
true to say that in cold war one there
was a great deal of
uh of caricaturing of the other side but
that wasn't
by any means the worst thing about one
the nuclear brinkmanship and the proxy
wars that cost
enormous numbers of lives from southeast
asia to
to central america and sub-saharan
africa
i think you can have a cold war without
those things certainly without the
nuclear brinkmanship and the
proxy wars but i think it's almost
inevitable that in the way
things are currently going that the
rhetoric on both sides
is becoming more and more hostile
and attitudes towards the chinese
government uh are becoming more and more
negative
uh in in the western world the pew group
showed that with some remarkable survey
data
back in october but my argument for cold
war ii
is not an argument against
a happy and cordial relationship i just
don't think a happy and cordial
relationship is possible
with this chinese government pursuing
these strategic goals
the thing we're trying to avoid is hot
war three i mean we do not want the us
and china to end up in a shooting war
whether it's over taiwan
uh or the south china sea or some other
issue
and the great point of cold war one was
to avoid
world war three it was to avoid a
nuclear exchange between the united
states and the soviet union and it did
that
contained the soviets expansion pretty
peacefully in the sense that there
wasn't a
head-to-head war over uh europe uh and
and i think that's really the point of
cold war that you'd rather have a cold
war than a hot war and i think that's
that's why cold wars happen and why
ultimately they're preferable
to making a series of miscalculations
which i think we're still well capable
of doing
that produce world war three it's not
difficult to imagine
a major escalation happening over an
issue like taiwan
and if you talk to people of the us
military i think of my
old friend jim stavridis who's just
published a novel about this
the scenarios are pretty terrifying
because the u.s china war would very
quickly escalate
from the taiwan strait to bombing of
mainland targets and then potentially to
nuclear exchanges that's that's how
steve reedus imagines it in his novel so
as i've been arguing now for more than
two years um
it you'd rather have cold war ii than
world war three
okay so you say that we should compete
with china but not copy it
so what does that competition look like
i think it looks like
what we currently see in the realm of
vaccines
where the west is able to take advantage
of its technological
edge and the greater competition that
there is when it comes to vaccine
development in the western world i mean
the competition between companies
biotech companies like moderna
and beyond tech is one of the reasons we
ended up with mrna
vaccines i think it looks like that in
artificial intelligence
one of the striking things about ai is
that the us still has a
qualitative lead partly because the best
chinese
researchers in ai end up working in the
united states and often stay
and ultimately become citizens so i
think this is a technological contest
i think cold war ii will be much more uh
a race
uh in technology than cold war one was
of course there was a
tech race a space race uh in in
cold war one and i think there will be
in cold war ii and a cyberspace
race and right now the us leads in i
think
most of the key domains but it will not
continue to lead
unless it really does uh maintain that
level of
investment in research and development
and competition which is really the key
to producing the best results uh and so
we mustn't make the mistake of thinking
that the way to compete with china
is through economic planning and by my
account we now have three plans coming
from the biden administration
uh in the form of major legislation huge
amounts of expenditure
total bill of around six trillion
dollars and i look at that and i ask are
we about to repeat the mistakes
of the 1960s and 70s when it seemed as
if
the only way to compete with the soviet
union was to do economic planning
the way they did that turned out to be a
completely
wrong conclusion and the way the united
states won the cold war was in fact with
with a free market economic model under
ronald reagan uh not with the kind of
thing john kenneth gobraith was arguing
for in the 1960s
well actually i'm intrigued that you
brought up chinese researchers and
scientists in ai for example
as you know in in america and in the
west in general there's been a greater
suspicion of chinese
nationals or ethnic chinese working
in stem stem areas where do you think
what do you what role do you think they
play in this sort of future competition
between the two great powers or should
they be
welcomed uh into the west or do you
think that we should be
careful being careful about what they
can take back to china
well this is a huge issue in a way that
it wasn't in
in cold war one there were relatively
few uh
soviet citizens in the united states at
any point
uh in the cold war that were uh in the
later part of the cold war exchanges but
they were on a tiny scale compared with
the really huge amounts
of exchange that there is between china
and the u.s
hundreds of thousands of chinese
students until recently at american
universities and often studying
stem subjects a really significant
number of graduate students working in
in key areas such as artificial
intelligence or quantum computing
and it's true to say uh and this is
something that that we know from
uh from the fbi that there has been
espionage as a consequence
we know that the chinese government uses
all kinds of means to try
to hack western technology
uh breakthroughs often through cyber
means but also through
human intelligence and this creates an
enormous
problem because of course if if one
chinese national working at one big tech
company turns out to be a spy
then suspicion falls on the others and
unfortunately that can include
uh american citizens uh often
uh people from chinese uh of chinese
heritage who've lived in the united
states for
many years uh so i do think we have to
remember that
uh one of the bleaker features of
american history in the 20th century was
the way in which
uh hostility grew towards uh
german americans uh in world war one and
world war ii and of course
in world war ii towards japanese
americans who were treated shamefully
we mustn't repeat that that history and
i i do see dangers
of that a few years ago more than a
decade ago i used the word chimerica
to describe that period of symbiotic
interaction
between the us and china well there are
many chimericans
uh and some of them are good friends of
mine these are people who may have been
born in china but have worked for many
years
in the united states and have become
american citizens when i became an
american citizen by far the largest
group
uh alongside me in an oakland auditorium
uh were in fact people born in china
and so we can't cast aspersions
on the commitment of chinese americans
to uh the country they've sworn
allegiance to if we start doing that
we're going to be back in the in the
battle days of uh of the 1940s
uh and i of course i'm very conscious
that i'm talking
uh to someone whose surname is is you
and may uh
be encountering uh in the uk some of the
kind of uh
anti-asian prejudice that one reads
about
on both sides of the atlantic that can't
be the way this plays out
it is the chinese communist party that
we are concerned
to combat uh in cold water we do not
want the ccp to become more powerful in
the world than it already is
uh that is quite different from uh
expressing antagonism
to people of of chinese ethnic origin
neil ferguson thank you so much for
joining spectator tv and you can read
neil ferguson's new book
doom the politics of catastrophe which
is out now
if you enjoyed that conversation you
might also enjoy my podcast series
chinese whispers where i look into
chinese politics society and its history
a link should be up on the screen now
and that's it for this week
thanks to all of our guests as ever send
any thoughts you have about the show to
spectator tv
at spectator dot co dot uk and to make
sure you never miss a future episode
click subscribe on the bottom right of
the screen to follow our youtube channel
see you next week
[Music]
you